der Schultag ist vorbei du schmeißt
deine Schultasche in die Ecke und du
riechst Kartoffelpüree Fischstäbchen und
Spinat so hat sich meine Kindheit
angefühlt das war der beste Moment des
Tages wenn man es geschafft hatte und
wusste ab jetzt wird gechillt und genau
dieses Gefühl möchte ich mir heute
wiederholen ich werde einen Tag essen
wie in meiner Kindheit und was macht das
heute noch mit mir ist Kindheit Essen
wirklich so geil finden wir es gemeinsam
heraus mit einem Frühstück zudem ist ihr
seht schon wahrscheinlich Müsli geben
wird und nicht irgendein sondern mein
absolutes Lieblingsmusik aus der
Kindheit Lion series ich weiß nicht ob
diese Werbung hat mich einfach kaputt im
Kopf gemacht so wenn man so einen
löffelei gegessen hat und dann so jetzt
habe ich das bestimmt schon 10 Jahre
nicht mehr gegessen wir gehen erst das
Müsli und dann nehme ich an
da gibt's nur eine große Portion müsste
nee geilste daran fand ich immer diese
schoko-milch die man am Ende hat
[Musik]
das ist wirklich crazy süß
ganz ehrlich schmeckt trotzdem gut aber
ich würde es eher so als Süßigkeit Essen
und auf gar keinen Fall jeden Morgen was
sie aber auch immer gerne getrunken habe
was ja auch als sehr gesund angepriesen
wird ist aktiviert denn es unterstützt
mein Immunsystem
wer braucht Proteinshakes das war damals
wahrscheinlich wirklich so das was ich
mir am ehesten gewünscht hätte als
Frühstück in der Realität sah mein
Frühstück häufig anders aus ich habe von
meiner Mom wirklich übelst liebevolle
Butterbrote bekommen bisschen Obst dazu
und habe sie kategorisch in meiner
Schultasche verschimmeln lassen weil ich
habe immer irgendwie probiert mit
anderen Schulkindern zu tauschen und so
ein Schoko hören nicht hin oder so zu
bekommen was heutiger Perspektive übelst
dumm aber als Kind man wird einfach
magisch angezogen von diesem Zeug ich
weiß nicht bis heute mag ich deshalb
nicht so gerne Aufschnitt weil ich also
zu ihre so diese Butterbrote die ich
über alles gehabt habe mit Aufschnitt
ihr könnt mal in die Kommentare
schreiben was ist für euch so das
kindheitsfrühstück lass mir das jetzt
noch schmecken und zum Mittagessen
gibt's den Klassiker schlechthin
Fischstäbchen Kartoffelpüree und Spinat
Stopp Zucker Cerealien ungesundes Essen
jetzt kann ich doch nicht den ganzen Tag
über auch noch ungesund trinken deshalb
habe ich eher ab die Unterstützer des
heutigen Videos ich habe mir Anfang des
Jahres vorgenommen ein bisschen auf
meine Figur zu achten bisschen
sportlicher zu werden und bisschen
weniger ungesunde Dinge mir zuzuführen
und trinken ein großer Faktor bis dahin
und deshalb habe ich mich mit R
zusammengetan wenn ihr euch zum Beispiel
mal umguckt das hier ist eine Friteuse
das ist ein Blumentopf aber das hier ist
keine einfache Flasche das hier ist
nämlich eine speziell von Erb
entwickelte Flasche auf welcher ihr
duftpots platzieren könnt den zieht ihr
einfach hoch und sobald ihr das tut wird
beim Trinken Luft zirkuliert so dass ihr
im Rachenraum Geschmack wahrnehmt und
das funktioniert wirklich ich habe hier
im Kirsch Pott drauf ich sage euch
ehrlich es hat mich geflasht und das
Flash mich bis heute wenn ich daran
denke
und das ist schmecke ich Kirsche ich
habe da vor 10 Sekunden Wasser rein
gefüllt dieses Erlebnis wird durch
unsere Sinne hervorgerufen und man nennt
es retronasales riechen mit Erb habe ich
es geschafft deutlich mehr Wasser zu
trinken an so einem normalen Tag und ihr
könntet das genauso die Pots gibt's
wirklich in allen verschiedenen
Geschmacksrichtungen sei es
Holunderblüte Cola und die Flasche könnt
ihr selbst gestalten also verschiedene
Farben oder wie ich die steel nehmen
wenn ihr jetzt Lust auf mehr habt dann
checkt er ab ab benutzt unbedingt den
Code Max mit Doppel x für 10% auf alles
viel Spaß und viel Spaß weiter mit dem
Video ich habe hier den Klassiker Iglo
Fischstäbchen Iglo Spinat und ein paar
Kartoffeln dazu es gibt viele Leute die
lieben sogar das Kartoffelpüree aus der
Tüte so auch Lara z.B aber ich sage euch
ehrlich ich persönlich mag es so und
meine Mom war auch immer so
aufopferungsvoll und hat selbst
kartoffelpüre gemacht ich schneide die
Kartoffeln jetzt in gleich große Stücke
so dass wir sie ein bisschen vorkochen
können muss ich euch jetzt ein Tutorial
machen für dieses Gericht ich glaube das
hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal
gegessen jeder schon mal gemacht aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist es einfach ein
zeitloser Klassiker
hier nicht wirklich gesund das Dinger
ich glaube als Kind fast alles essen ne
dann gehen wir einfach einen Topf machen
ein bisschen aufköcheln ich habe nicht
gedacht dass ich mal Fischstäbchen mit
Kartoffelpüree und Spinat mache auf
diesem Kanal aber es gibt immer ein
erstes Mal jetzt gehen wir ein bisschen
Öl in die Pfanne und das Folgen unsere
Fischstäbchen früher hat mich meine Mama
immer gefragt so wie viele schaffst du
und ich habe irgendwie übertriebene Zahl
gesagt so 12 oder so
unser wasserkocht geh mal ein bisschen
Salz hinein ganz kurz Unterbrechung
Leute Ich sage euch so viel wenn ihr mir
einen Gefallen tun wollt und auch euch
zukünftigen Gefallen tun wollt dann
schaut mal bei Blog vorbei guck mal in
die Videobeschreibung da kommt nämlich
ganz bald was auf euch zu Newsletter
Anmeldung gibt's auch folgt mal rein ich
bin sehr sehr aufgeregt weil er passiert
bald was und dieses wunderschöne Schild
hängt nicht umsonst im Hintergrund
das wäre cool und es geht ganz weit los
eine Sache noch ganz wichtig ich wollte
schon mal danke sagen weil no joke ich
habe einmal in dem Video Blog erwähnt
und wir haben über 4000 Follower auf
Instagram deshalb Kuss schon mal an der
Stelle an euch jetzt folgen die
Kartoffeln die kochen wir vor eine
wichtige Zutaten am Ende auch noch die
spielt auch später noch mal eine Rolle
Ketchup beste mit Ketchup
Alter
okay weiter geht's ja
gebraten oder Braten noch vor sich hin
deswegen diese wunderschöne goldgelbe
Farbe werden auch einfach mit der Hand
gedreht ja Alter was soll denn erzählen
Mann wir machen Fischstäbchen Spinat und
Kartoffelpüree wir sehen uns gleich wenn
ich das Püree mache Kartoffeln
Kartoffeln in den Topf geben wieder
platzieren Kartoffelstampfer suchen
Kartoffelstampfer in die Kartoffeln
drücken Püree herstellen Kartoffelstampf
zu Püree umwandeln wenn gewünscht durch
siebstreichen weil wir keine Idioten
sind einfach so essen Vorzugs diese
warme Milch einarbeiten gleichzeitig
Butter hinzufügen sei es hinzufügen bin
gerade so eine Roboter Version von
Gordon Ramsay
Spinat noch nachwürzen oder nicht aus
heutiger Perspektive ja früher nein
deshalb Muskat kennst du das so wenn du
eine ganze Muskatnuss isst stirbst du
rauchen
wir sind noch nicht ganz da ein bisschen
Milch muss noch wir müssen das halt
einfach so machen wie meine Mama
so muss ein Kartoffelpüree aussehen so
ein Kartoffelpüree was eine Mama macht
die nicht so viel Zeit jetzt richten wir
das Ganze an nehmen uns natürlich ein
paar schöne Fischstäbchen auch immer
ganz wichtig dass das schön angerichtet
ist sonst kann man für gar nicht essen
fünf Stück gerade Zahlen wunderschönes
Häufchen dass ich da gemacht habe ja mit
dem Blog an die Masse
[Musik]
dreiländer jetzt
nehmen wir das auseinander Ketchup dazu
oh jetzt ist es perfekt darmspinat
Kartoffelpüree Fischstäbchen jeder kennt
das jeder liebt es endlich probieren ich
glaube egal wie alt man ist wenn man von
diesem Gericht setzt man hat einfach
Lust ich nehme hier ein bisschen vom
Fischstäbchen
genau wie meine moms gemacht hat also
die konnten sie das ist schon sehr fest
vor so einzelne Chance ist wirklich eins
zu eins für meine moms gemacht hat ist
werden auf jeden Fall einige Knöpfe
gerade durch meine Geschmacksknospen
gedrückt die mir gute Gefühle geben so
auf kindheitsbasis der Spinat der Spinat
sage ich ehrlich der war so dann hat man
auch gern mal übrig gelassen als nur
noch ganz klar
zu gesund
bis man Papaya geschaut hat und dann
weiß ich immer so
ganz ehrlich geiles Gericht dann habe
ich irgendwie gebraucht ich fühle mich
jetzt gerade wieder gegen glücklicher
kleiner Max so richtig richtig glücklich
weil der kleine Max aber mehr so den
ganzen Tag im Freibad war getaucht ist
geschwommen ist richtig am Arsch war und
dann hat meine Mama Schwimmbad Auflauf
gemacht Nudelauflauf den es immer nur
dann gab wenn wir wirklich uns
körperlich verausgabt haben davor was
ich bis heute nicht wusste dass ich
unter anderem daran dass er ziemlich
ungesund ist und den machen wir jetzt
ich habe meine Mama nach dem Gericht
gefragt und sie hätte das jetzt zu sagen
schwimmbadauflauf das war der Inbegriff
des Glück der Glückseligkeit nach einem
durchtobten Tag im Schwimmbad alles was
man wissen muss dazu wirklich meine Mom
das war wirklich das Beste immer wenn
sie das gemacht hat hier ist alles was
wir brauchen wir haben einmal
Dörrfleisch was so viel wie Bacon heißt
Bauchspeck geräuchert italienischen
Kochschinken hat sie auch gesagt wichtig
am besten
italiano weil meine Mama ist ja quasi
Italienerin also die ist zum Teil in
Italien aufgewachsen bzw Spirelli dann
vier Eier zwei Becher Sahne 3 gehackte
Zwiebel und geschälte Tomaten wir fangen
an indem wir uns ein paar schöne Würfel
aus dem dörfleisch Schneiden so sieht
das ganze gewürfelt aus und ich gebe es
einfach in die Pfanne den Bauchspeck
lassen wir aus dass er ein bisschen
kleiner wird Fett schwitzt draußen und
in dem Fett braten wir auch unsere
Zwiebeln an außerdem schalte ich noch
das Wasser an und werde es kräftig sein
denn wir müssen unsere Nudeln 160 Grad
40 Minuten unser Bauchspeck hat schön
Farbe bekommen jetzt gebe ich drei
gehackten Zwiebeln hinzu unser Wasser
kocht und wir geben 500 g Fusilli hinein
brauchen aber noch eine Masse die quasi
unsere Nudeln verbindet im Auflauf dafür
nehme ich vier Eier und schlagt die
einfach mal hier straight uh in die
Sahne hinein auch was was ich noch nie
gesehen habe oder gemacht habe also rohe
Eier in Sahne rein einmal schön
verkürzen zu einer Masse Salz Pfeffer
rein außerdem weil wir noch nicht genug
Fett Kohlenhydrate haben nehmen wir
warmes Wasser dazu kräftig hinein haben
und Butterflocken Komma am Ende drüber
das ist soweit wir schütten die Nudeln
ab jetzt schnappen wir uns eine
Auflaufform geben die Nudeln hinein
verteilen sie ein wenig und jetzt kommt
alles zusammen zunächst unsere Zwiebeln
mit dem dörfleisch alles schön vermengen
vor der Geruch ist schon mal Geruch im
verteilen jetzt im Schinken dazugeben
das ist so untypisch für alles was meine
Mom sonst zu kochen die würde eigentlich
niemals so viel Sahne und keine Ahnung
so untraditionell kochen und so deshalb
ist es vielleicht auch ein Gericht dass
ich so sehr liebe weil es einfach mal so
was anderes war vor ehrlich gesagt
ehrlich du bist glaube ich auch lieben
ich denke auch ich kann es mir sehr sehr
gut vorstellen jetzt nehmen Sie unsere
pomodore Platin geben die einfach einmal
so da rein und jetzt wenn das ganze auch
schon ein bisschen abgekühlt ist kommt
die Parmesan Sahne Mischung an
und das gute ist laut meiner Mama jetzt
so wie es jetzt ist kann man es perfekt
stehen lassen und quasi ziehen lassen so
dass es den den Geschmack aufsaugt und
sich verteilt deshalb ist auch der
Schwimmbad auch wenn meine Mama hat das
dann immer vorbereitet dann sind wir
zurück waren hatte das Ding schnell
fertig gebacken und genau mit ein
bisschen Salz dran dann reiben wir noch
mal ordentlich Parmesan drüber und dann
kann das Ding auch schon in den Ofen so
langsam aber sicher habe ich alles mit
Parmesan Folge gerieben der Backofen ist
auf Temperatur mein Hunger könnte nicht
größer sein einzige was jetzt noch fehlt
sind laut meiner Mama Butterflöckchen
oben auf der Parmesan Decke diese
verteilen wir auch noch und dann kommt
das ganze auch schon in den Backofen 160
Grad 40 Minuten
gut und werde genauso wie es mir hoffe
jetzt ab ins Schwimmbad
raus aus dem Schwimmbad bzw aus dem
Fitnessstudio da ist das Ding gerade
noch mal den Grill angeschaltet dass wir
oben schön diese knusprigen Elemente
haben und so sei wirklich immer aus wenn
meine Mami gemacht hat ich freue mich so
darauf
in der Luft gerade habe ich noch nie
gerochen oder ich habe sie so oft
geraucht habe
heute abend bist du Bauchschmerzen holen
wir uns ein schönes Stück
schwimmbadauflauf und zack ich höre ein
kleines natürlich willst du einen
kleinen gewissen großes weißt du und das
ist jetzt genau das Ding das hält
zusammen weil das Ei gestockt ist wie so
ein Kuchen auch hier guck mal man sieht
oh Junge ist das geil
auf Ketchup und jetzt kommt nicht so an
die Seite nicht so bisschen nein wir
gehen komplett rüber so ist man immer
Auflauf
ich schwöre das ist ein großer Moment
für mich gerade jetzt ganz ohne schaue
ich mir das so geil so dass ich das so
machen kann durch koche seit 200 Jahren
nur auf meinem Kanal aber dass ich den
Schwimmbad Auflauf von meiner Mom und
der wirklich nicht schwer ist aber der
so ein einzigartigen Geschmack hat sich
den machen kann schmeckt eins zu eins
von meiner Mama Eric probiere das bitte
ist das jetzt Schaufeln so weg Alter
das ehrenlos das ist für mich gerade
wirklich eine 11 von 10 so man dachte
erst so meine Mama kann nicht kochen
jedes Gericht aber es ist einfach krank
alles daran ist geil der Schinken ist
geil der Speck ist geil die literweise
Ketchup die man dazu ist sind übelst
geil scheiß auf diese fertigen
piss-sachen Nudel Schwimmbad Auflauf
für dich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich rufe jetzt an